まあそうですね語彙力は確かにとても
重要ですが朝食じゃなくて朝ごはんとか
みたいにそのシチュエーションに最も適切
な言葉じゃなくてもほとんどの場合は問題
なく伝わりますそれに
咎めるとかおびただしいとか
べからずとかN1にしか出てこないような
単語を無理やり日常会話に入れようとし
たら多くの日本人をむしろちょっと引いて
しまうと思いますまあですのでまずは丁寧
語それから日本のマナーを勉強した方が
いいと思います
まあそうですね日本人はどちらかといえば
相手が
丁寧な言い方を使おうとしているかどうか
が気になりますのでその後で単語の勉強に
精を出したらいいんじゃないかなと思い
ます
性能を出すの意味は何ですかってだから
そうですね
敬語とマナーはとても大事ですねでも
外国人と話す時にあえて
敬語を使わない日本人もたくさんいますし
そもそも正しい敬語が使いこなせない日本
人も多いですですのでまぁ敬語はそこまで
勉強しなくていいと思いますまあ外国人で
ある僕が言うのはあれかもしれないんです
けど皆さんが普段からSNSを使っている
今の時代では
読む力がとても大事ですので
敬語の勉強より
漢字の勉強の方がよっぽど役に立つんじゃ
ないかなと思います
書き順も必須です
そうですね
漢字はとても大切ですねまあでもスマホを
勝手に生きる今の時代では
文字を実際に書く機会が劇的に減りました
し日本人でも
漢字が書けない人がたくさんいます先生も
そうですなんで私の個人的な意見なんです
けど書き順とかじゃなくて自分の言いたい
ことが相手に
伝わっているかどうかはその方が
重要だと思いますそういった意味で文法と
発音に力を入れるべきだと思います
ちょっときついこと言わせていただきます
が発音が
完璧だと思い込んでいて実はまあまあ
間違っているっていう人がたくさんいます
どんな人だろう
日本語の発音はとても簡単ですボインは5
つしかありませんし英語と違って音が
変わったりしませんでも僕みたいになり
たいのであればおびただしい数の単語を
覚える必要がありますいいですか発音でも
漢字でもマナーでもない
字幕なしでアニメを見たいというのであれ
ば語彙力が全てだ
覚悟して勉強に挑め